here's a young fella right here who's
Evans going through some ministers and
he tells us a little bit was good game
game buzz buzz let's is er hope y'all
are doing well during these quarantine
times I gotta gotta got the debate club
for you hot technical for you
training day training day or bad boys
which one you guys going with Denzel or
Will Smith and Martin Lawrence both
classics both awesome
I'd love for both of y'all shall buy
watch your videos on the on 2:49 I loved
your coverage bro do your podcast helped
me through some dark times brother cuz I
do I don't think you're out yet got a
lot of problems with you know you know
the dark arts hater
maybe yeah to keep pushing guys watch
the gang game buzz buzz good luck with
everything
his energies through the room his his
email this guy's name is Shawn and his
email with Celtic rage that dudes
fighting some demons done or Celtic rage
again yeah that dudes in the 12th round
with some [ __ ] demons I think 30
rounds with pure Pharma what's up
showing man I appreciate the message bro
thanks for getting in touch with us yeah
we love you good luck [ __ ] demons
yeah dude everybody's got a man asking
about [ __ ] El Camino you in the
office yeah it was Sophie's baby
he's right drinking carrot juice and
[ __ ] right no novel or some [ __ ] I
can't wait to read it
yes real smart man yeah he's an
interesting dude yeah I'm a fan - yeah
hell yeah trained a 56% yeah mm-hmm that
boys is good but nothing bad boys is
like fun training days like that gritty
oh do train day is that real [ __ ]
[Music]
nothing
[Music]